so there was a research study where they
had three bottles of wine they had a
cheap wine they had a mid-price wine and
they had an expensive one and they had
people try them out and so people said
oh I think the most expensive wine is
the best the middle price is the middle
and the cheapest wine was the worst and
that's not that surprising except when
the researchers explained that all three
wines were the same and so in a very
real way when you raise your prices you
do actually make something that's more
valuable because if that's what we're
trying to get at which is value price
confers value to your product a more
expensive thing is perceived in real
terms as more valuable even if the
actual core product is the same why
would you not want to make your thing
more valuable